[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
we are featuring Kevin sis car today
from New York City
what is up Kevin hey Alan how's it going
I'm excited to be here thanks for having
me on the simulation yeah super pumped
and Kevin is all the way on NYC we are
doing a special episode today where we
are doing collab between simulation and
Kevin's podcast ambition today so
Kevin's the managing director at founder
Institute in New York City he is also a
founding partner at equity token and
co-founder of the New York City
innovation collective and venture
partner at outbound ventures so you've
been hustling it now for three and a
half years with entrepreneurs helping
them across the world now get their
ideas to fruition impacting people
you've also been doing ambitions today
now helping get people's voices out
there that are impacting the world so
what have been some of your favorite
takeaways from doing this work yeah for
sure and thank you for the intro and so
we actually just last night we've
graduated our winter cohort 14 amazing
companies and I've actually now helped
start over a hundred companies here in
New York which is pretty amazing to
think in the short time but you know
some of my favorite lessons well some of
it there's there's some favorite lessons
from the class from the accelerator and
there's so my favorite lessons from the
podcast I would like to highlight that I
you know last night one of the things we
talked a lot about and I think this is
sort of a trend in 2018 with improving
diversity we've been making efforts at
that at founder Institute for almost two
to three years now if not longer and we
do these through these things got
fellowships we have this one for space
we have one for veterans we have one for
girls in tech and we have a partnership
with girls in tech to help change those
ratios right and
the ad right now the average ratio of
female CEOs in Silicon Valley is 17% and
I'm excited because last night we
graduated a 67% female cohort of founder
Institute which was which is amazing I
felt so you know I think the lesson
there right it's like you asked about
lessons that I've learned maybe they're
not direct lessons from you know someone
telling us something but things we've
learned from our experience is this
stuff works right and it doesn't it
takes time right every man does it take
time but if you played the long game
right it's just so much more rewarding
and you can make such a bigger impact
right then if you're concerned about you
know the next paycheck or trying to
figure something out within a month like
you just you kind of need to take the
time early on to find your North Star
and and keep walking towards it you know
week after week month after month year
after year to get where you really want
to go so that's one I love how the ratio
now of your graduates is leaning more in
the direction a female it's interesting
New York is a very diverse place so as
SF so to see people of a diverse thought
and diverse places around the world be
founders of companies and having them
bring these philosophies from around the
world and baked into their companies and
teaching people here out west what
they've been learning people out here in
the West teach them what they've been
learning and then also just this this
hustle you're right that so it's about
figuring out that thing that is your
North Star whatever that is and
hopefully bring some value to the world
but even though we all a lot of us
through entrepreneurship start very poor
and we hustle very hard through that
being or and then only after a couple
years really does it pay off and we have
to get through those couple years for it
to actually pay off so I'm glad you
highlight that those are good points
yeah and the other thing I would
highlight too and I'm gonna give give a
shout out to simulation
I believe you had a day arrest he
started founder Institute you had him I
think on the first episode of simulation
which for those of you who want to like
know more about the cosmic psychology of
entrepreneurs and great episode a really
good episode you guys really got into
like into some into some stuff on there
and but I had a day one ambition today
after talking with him he he always says
this thing he always says the only time
a company dies is when the founder quits
and for a while I was like alright fun
cliche sounds good but now that I'm into
this ways it's so true right like the
only time a company fails is when the
founder says I am no longer gonna push
the ball up the hill anymore right maybe
it's because you got another job offer
there's an opportunity cost maybe it's
because you ran out of money maybe it's
because you had a kid life happened
right like but a lot of founders just
push through these milestones like month
after quarter after year right and the
ones that just don't give up I've seen
founders burn it down to zero from four
hundred employees and then rebuild and
build multi-million hundred million
dollar companies again right and so you
just can't give up you just got to keep
going and pushing forward if you truly
believe it it's possible and nicking it
can make the world a better place man
thinking about the visual of someone
pushing a boulder up the mountain and
then when they are hitting these little
these you you know it's interesting
because I'm starting to paint out this
analogy more but as you push up there
are these plateaus and the plateaus it
kind of gets a little easier maybe you
get in some flow there's a plateau it's
easier to push the boulder and then you
go on another up again and like right
now we're fundraising or patreon at our
studio to try and become sustainable and
we're on this up right there's so many
of these forces around us that are going
like you need to pay you need to pay you
need to
and it's like and it's like why am I
doing this again like you've just been
so much easier to just not have to worry
about this and just you know do whatever
else and so that's these forces that are
trying to push you down and if you drop
once you drop this Boulder and you run
away from this idea like a day who said
that is the moment that becomes that the
boulder just rolls down and then it's
done so if you're if you're fully able
to dedicate yourself through the
hardships of these really tough inclines
but also these plateaus where you can
celebrate a little more when you've
achieved some some of your milestones
and then you keep going and keep us
aligned entrepreneurship is the best
thing you'll ever do
yeah and I think I actually really like
let's just keep going with this analogy
because it's awesome yeah we can even
make the boulder a snowball right so it
gets bigger though the more higher you
push it right which is a whole other
thing to think about but I'd say another
milestone that founders need to be
thinking about and it's underrated is
going full-time on your business right I
had someone the other day who was single
and in their 20s being like I don't
understand why everyone just doesn't go
full-time on their 24 time on their
business I was like well some people
have kids some people have jobs and
health insurance in like this is not an
easy leap to make where you've quit
something that's a sure thing you have a
house you can get your payment right and
and to just bet all the chips on
upcoming revenue right and so to your
Boulder analogy right like not being
full-time on your business is like
leaving that Boulder every day for eight
hours watching it roll back and then
sort of like coming back in the evenings
and like pushing it back up right and so
you know another lesson from the show I
would say you getting to being full-time
on your business regardless of revenues
regardless of you know it's more about
your own personal runway and what allows
you to do that focus with that much time
it's a huge milestone that founders need
to be thinking about
I'm really happy we're continuing on
this analogy I like how you I liked how
you described how as with the bolt and
gets pushed up the hill once you gain
like it starts as a very sorts like a
little pebble or like a grain of sand
really a marble sized idea and then you
get like maybe attraction from like a
dozen people around you that are
interested in it and then it becomes a
little bit bigger more people are
talking about it now and then once
you're actually selling this product
you've built it there's more people
being impacted by it the boulder keeps
getting larger and larger in size and
then if you add things like you said
family or if you add a needing to leave
to go do something for like health
purposes or whatever these different
variables are that pull people away from
their focus on their on their business
you know usually we use the example of
nurturing a child here you you you stop
nurturing the child the child is going
to experience some sort of of nutrition
you know defect at that moment and so in
that period of time so with the boulder
it might be like you said it starts
rolling back a bit if you can find a
successful platform to leave the boulder
on and one of the plateaus maybe or put
a platform in there maybe somebody with
a good skill set then that can hold it
in place while before you come back that
would be ideal I wanted to ask you about
your the last couple of years as you've
been identifying entrepreneurs that are
China that are doing ideas that are
changing the world that are also with up
without bound ventures the companies
that you guys are looking at with the
NYC innovation collective these these
these companies that are trying to
change the world how do you identify
companies that have really strong and
founders that have really strong values
and first principles
yeah sure so let's take a step back a
second how do you define values and
first principles before I tell you a
bunch of founders that happen yeah so so
for example like one of our values that
we identify people with is like their
passion to want to change the world
their passion to want to make the world
a better place and so that's obviously
subjective thing but at the same time
when you look at our world if it's
something like wanting to progress the
sustainability of the planet we're
wanting to do things like help in people
with Alzheimer's or help people that are
underprivileged in underprivileged areas
or help with with creating a more
sustainable future in terms of energy or
food production and so the more that
identify myself with those values and I
and I see people building those
industries the more I associate myself
with myself with them rather than maybe
somebody that's making a maybe making a
game that is just men like Andy brush or
some so yeah yes so it's tricky right
and I'm gonna you know I everyone that's
out there should go definitely check out
the episode with Alan and a day out
because you guys talked a lot about
waking people up right and and where we
help founders where I typically help
founders is I will help someone as early
as I have an idea I have three ideas I
don't know what to do with them and
someone who's as far along as you know I
have $100,000 of revenue right and so
everyone sort of in that early stage you
know figuring out these things and then
formalizing them right but I would say
at the earliest stage right like
you guys made this view in a day I made
this analogy we're like a lot of people
need to be awoken to really realize
their potential and not just go watch
Netflix or go about their day and you
know waste time and traffic commuting
and all this stuff right and so but you
made the point that people don't people
can be like the grizzly bear when they
do wake up but they don't wake up
fighting right they wake up and slowly
come out of hibernation and like they're
tired and the groggy and then slowly
over time over actually months to like a
year people change and become almost
this new person they reprogrammed
themselves to be an entrepreneur right
but I would say during that process you
don't know what you don't know right and
you don't which means you think you
should maybe be paying attention to some
things but in reality your mentors never
that's already gone through this journey
there's telling you need to defer you're
paying attention over here right and I
would say to your point about values and
passion that is one of them that you
just have to pay attention to and I
could tell you from working with
hundreds of founders that they don't
want it right they're like how do I get
investors how do i how do I get revenue
I got it I need a technical co-founder I
got to get this built right and it's
like that's cool but literally just take
five days right take a step back figure
out like is this really what you want to
be doing is just really aligned with
like your passion right with your life
experience what you care about because
and if it does amazing right you need to
go do that right but if it doesn't this
is the analogy right
passion is equivalent to the amount of
gas in your tank and so if you don't
take the five days that step back to
make sure you have the passion I promise
you you will die your company will die
somewhere around nine months to five
years right at some point in there
you're gonna run out of gas you're gonna
be like
screw it I'm not doing this anymore
right and you're gonna give up and
you're gonna quit and that's why the
company is gonna fail and the boulder is
gonna fall back down right back down the
hill
so passion is so important now all those
other things those business things all
didn't get layered on top of that and
they're equally as important but it's
like this is the foundation and the
hierarchy that you need to be thinking
about because life happens and in those
moments when life happens what are you
going to choose
you're nailing it it's so important to
go back and take a take a third person's
perspective on what you're doing and
what you're building because if it's not
aligned with what you truly care about
like you said so many people are just
how do I get more money how do I get
more founders how do I get more
technical development on my project how
do I get sales venture money we don't
take a step back often enough to look
back and say that do I want to build
this for the next five years because if
we did that more often then we would see
potentially ourselves going oh maybe I
want to build something with a little
more impact in a different area of
expertise or maybe I don't want to be
working at this company nine-to-five
maybe I want to take a bigger risk maybe
I'm at a point where I'm in my mid 20s
or early 30s or wherever I'm at and I do
not want to work 9:00 to 5:00 for
someone else
sometimes there's not enough people
around you that are also entrepreneurs
that are pushing you really hard and
telling you yes you can yes you can
achieve this goal of starting a business
you totally can do it sometimes there's
not enough people doing that and because
of that we don't question our
nine-to-five enough yeah and the reality
to here is let's say you give what you
want right let's say that you start this
company you didn't do that self work
right and it works right now you're
building this company for 15 to 25 years
because it's making you four ton of
money yeah you're doing something you
hate and now you're just trapped in your
own thing you created right and you know
there's reasons to figure out why you
just literally take the step back in the
beginning and figure out if this is
right for you and why you should be
doing this
yeah I can't even begin to imagine what
the boulder being like super massive and
then you're like at the at clearly a
good way up the mountain and it's so
massive boulder and you were just
sitting there holding it going why did I
bring this Boulder up this is so bad
it's so much better
to know every single step along the way
why you're doing this why you're
passionate about it for example with
with what we're doing at simulation the
reason why we're doing it is because we
want to design civilization in a way
that's more prosperous for everybody and
that helps us on this thousand-year
clock so that way we actually figure out
how to survive how to sustainably build
and especially how to self actualize
children in the world right now we we
have so many of these exponential
technologies running forth into our
world and we're very much so leaving
behind the conversation that parents
need to be having with their kids about
AI and automation and biotechnology and
all these different ways that our
society's tremendously being impacted
yeah yeah so let's so Alan let's let's
let's just get into it man while we're
on that well let's just this perfect
segue right so on admission today we
like to highlight we really start with
people's childhoods right and we like to
figure out why people are doing what
they're doing really getting into the
incidence we don't honestly care what
color yacht you drive now that you've
sold your 100 million dollar business
right we want to know how you got there
because those are the lessons that other
founders care about right so I want to
take a step back here I want to get into
the future in a little bit but you know
let's go back let's take it back to you
for a sec right give me give me just one
lesson or something from growing up
right that really had an impact I mean
like why do you care about the future
right like what it was a Star Trek like
was it an uncle who was super
entrepreneur entrepreneurial yeah tell
us your story a little bit what had an
impact on you
good question Washington so I think of a
big one or influencing me towards
entrepreneurship was knowing that
there's this this path that everybody
takes and I really like to go on the
other path and that's probably the main
point and analyzing society to the point
where I almost became like very
aware that almost all of my peers were
going down this path and I was like wow
that's
do we even know what alternative paths
exists
who has taught us about the other paths
the school system sure doesn't teach us
about the other path do our parents
teach us about the other paths do our do
our communities do our mentors do we
even have mentors when were 18 years old
telling us where we can go what we can
do so that's what really drew me to the
other path I wanted to be different I
wanted to be unusual I wanted to be an
very idiosyncratic figure that drew
other people to the other path I wanted
to go forth on this path and then tell
other people that were on the other path
like hey check out this other path look
at what you can do if you just say to
yourself I can do something different
and that that that's probably the
biggest driver for me yeah to get into
yeah and if you go back to what we were
saying earlier about founders right and
to what you just said everyone on that
other path you don't know what you don't
know right and so the moment you had
this like awakening you were like awoke
to a data point right we were like
you're like oh maybe I'll just I could
still go down that path but what else is
there right and you started to look
around and I think one of the most
underrated
things in the world is mentors right
everybody should have a mentor and I
don't think enough people do it I think
a lot of people have people they get
advice from or things on the internet
they read right but like you got to
really find people in the world that
you'd like that you maybe want to sort
of emulate and figure out how to get
their guidance in there and their their
mentorship I think that's super
important to achieving your goals
long term Wow the mentor aspect of
growing up is so crucial and this is
this actually has some literature
I'll talk on the literature quick before
I get into my example which is that
there were I forgot exactly when the
studies were done but the idea was that
if you have
there are a couple variables I learned
about the studies three years ago there
are a couple of variables that go into a
child or graduating from high school and
then choosing to leave their high school
to go to a prestigious university that
they got accepted into and a couple of
the variables that influence them are
things like did somebody in your high
school beforehand go to that University
so has somebody already made that has
somebody done that have they paved that
path before the second one is do you
have a counselor or a teacher or a
member of your community or a parent
that is actively saying you can do it
that you can make this decision you can
make this leap of faith you can actually
get there totally those the idea of
mentorship is a crucial part of the
influence of getting somebody from a
young age to be knowing that they can
bring their value and impact to the
world without feeling like they have to
go down the other path or be squashed
along the way and so for example with
with me I remember when I was when I was
19 first moving to Silicon Valley taking
this leap of faith one of the things
that I was telling myself over and over
again when I moved here was I need to
find a mentor I need to find somebody
that will take me under their wing that
will help me cuz I had these Word docs
full of ideas that I wanted to execute
but I needed somebody to be like no
that's not gonna work that's not gonna
work this might work but you need to do
XYZ to make it work go to this Meetup go
meet these people and just imagine if
you have somebody doing that now that
helps you so much versus you not knowing
what to do falling on your face a bunch
of extra times that you or don't need to
let save so much time and then even
today what was it yesterday yesterday I
just had one of my friends Wilson call
me and he's a younger guy and he's
really ambitious and he's wanting to
move to Silicon Valley and impact the
world and I'm giving him advice and last
week somebody else called me for
something similar and so this this is
exactly what I want to offer back to
people well this is exactly what we need
we need the system of 25 year olds
helping 20 year olds 20 year olds help
fifteen year olds this whole near-peer
near-peer experience and I have so many
thirty and thirty five and forty year
olds that I talk to all the time about
how to help maximize what I'm doing so
this whole mentorship is is crucial and
why don't we have this in our in our
high school system the closest thing we
have to a mentor is our is our teacher
in the high school system but what would
it be like if we actually made a like a
high a day in high school when you had
maybe the like a c-level exact from a
company in the in the area maybe a
health care company or food tech company
or or like a blockchain and crypto
company come in to the high school and
what if they were to talk for fifteen
minutes and maybe answer questions from
the from the high schoolers about what
they're building and how the young kids
can get involved maybe they can have a
day of of when the high schoolers go to
that company and immerse themselves in
what they're actually doing and they
provide the lunch for them and
everything something like that we don't
do this enough
we don't pair mentors with with students
enough so yeah you nailed it there yeah
for sure and you know you said the word
teacher shoutout to all the teachers
yesterday was National Teacher
Appreciation Day and I'm married to a
teacher so sure that's all the teachers
but yes we also need mentors right
because so many these teachers are
already overwhelmed they have classrooms
of like thirty to forty kids and like
studies show you're supposed to have
like twenty to twenty-five tops right
and yeah it's such a good point but and
I want to ask you to the question I know
your audience is probably very familiar
with the World's Fair but my audience I
think it's amazing I one of my favorite
things about you is you're all about the
future but the future at like a very
amazing almost science fiction level but
but right where that science fiction
point like touches reality right and so
I went to the World's Fair you had it in
Brooklyn this last year and it was some
amazing exhibitions there but for my
audience that may be does it know can
you give a quick recap of what the
World's Fair is
and and and what it's doing today and I
would love to hear like you know where
it's going yeah definitely so we did the
World's Fair for the last two and a half
years in New York in San Francisco back
and forth and so it's a two-day future
festival featuring some of the greatest
technology of let you can put your hands
on like a RV our drones Electric
skateboards 3d printers then we also
have a speaker stage going on both Bay's
buildeth talks about vertical farming or
neuroscience or AI or robotics all these
different talks as well and so we're
currently trying to figure out what's
going on with their finances because we
haven't been able to turn profitability
on the fares and we really want to make
it happen and this is like this so
crucial like if you want to throw these
massive big festivals that get people
inspired in the future it's so important
to figure out how to make them
sustainable and and you know that's a
huge part of entrepreneurship is either
you fundraise you get sponsors you get
ticket sales you sell VIP tickets um
there's so many aspects of this in order
to help make it happen and and we're
figuring that out we're thinking about
doing some smaller like maybe half day
or one-day events focused on topics like
AI and robotics and one event and that
may be AI and healthcare AI and FinTech
that kind of stuff so we're we're
figuring it out right now and but the
goal in mind is totally still to get to
a six-month 100 million person festival
as and we want to rebirth the idea of to
getting a big plot of land somewhere in
Houston and then having companies come
there for six straight months to exhibit
and speak and have people flying from
around the world over that six month
area to experience all these different
aspects of the future so that is totally
still on the radar if something says
such a cool event that we could throw
and inspire people with
yeah that would be amazing you know I
living in New York we still have all the
remnants of the nineteen you know mid
1900s World's Fair right in Flushing
Meadows product we have the the giant
earth the sphere the Unisphere the the
the towers for men and black that
everyone seems to know yeah no that'd be
amazing
best of luck yeah Kevin how about I ask
you one of our simulation questions
which is pool we have a growing
push right now for both globalization
and for technology to be exacerbating
wealth inequality it's occurring on
multiple fronts what do you think what
do you think's going on how do we build
a globalized world together how do you
balance like nationalism versus
collectivism across the planet and then
also how do you figure out what we're
gonna do about wealth and equality
well alright I want to separate that out
there because I feel like there was a
few things in there right so
globalization is definitely happening
and I think
you look at what's happening with
Cambridge analytic and Facebook and
Russia and the way that things can be an
influence influenced across borders just
by using the Internet it's amazing and I
think that's actually only gonna get
faster
I know blockchain is a bit of a buzzword
that a lot of people are sick of but
it's coming right so many talented
people have switched from you know
writing mobile apps to building out the
blockchain infrastructure and
decentralizing the internet so these
Cambridge analytic efface book trust
issues can't happen again
and so globalization is is here to stay
and probably only going to exacerbate
and the new nation borders will probably
be Earth and Mars at some point in the
amount of years but but so so we'll see
what happens there I mean do have any
thoughts on globalization before we we
jump to wealth inequality yeah do you
know that you read did you read 0 to 1
Peter Thiel's book I did a few years ago
yeah yeah the idea of having the 0 to
the 1 be the actual creativity or the
innovation of the idea and then the
one-to-many be the globalization aspect
of things I thought that that's a really
good way to put it and I'm totally for
the one-to-many like doing that as fast
as possible there's definitely certain
people that do that distribution that's
really important well I don't think
there's enough people that are working
on the 0 to 1 in a way that is driven by
ethics and philosophy and values and
principles of building a better world I
think there's a lot of people that work
on the 0 to 1 in a in a way that
distracts people from truth and you know
on the show I'm not you know Ron is
pushing me to be more raw and more real
and I am that and I want to be more raw
and real and not someone that hides
behind and everything's positive sort of
mentality and it's it's just not there's
people that are distracted and and and
I'm and I'm not and it's not ok to to
globalize our world for distraction for
the attention economy that's not
pher it's [ __ ] and it's distracting
people away from truth and and from and
from so many things that are so
important to building a sustainable
future so we know we'll address that
more on the show as we keep going around
it there's that word truth again you
know truth whose truth your truth my
truth you know be careful with truth I
just want to say that if we're all
looking for truth confirmation bias
cognitive dissonance keep those things
in mind and no one will get hurt
at the scene this time I want to say we
talked about on the show truth a lot and
truth our truth is things like the earth
being a sphere truth is things like the
earth orbiting the star truth this
thing's like your heart beating
approximately a hundred thousand times a
day to keep you alive truth is things
like the evolution of the cosmos these
are true things true things like you
think therefore you are these are true
things that we can agree on and I think
are important to have a fundamental
objective truth because if we keep this
postmodernist sort of mentality about
everyone has a subjective reality whose
truth true this true that we're actually
not going to get to a fundamental
objective layer of truth that we can
build our civilization on so we need to
get to that fundamental layer of
objective truth Kevin what do you think
about that before we get to the wealth
and quality convo
though is a question right like I mean
clearly you know truth truth equals
things back to my facts and data right
we know that but people believe in
different facts and data right and so
there's certain things people agree on
more like cancer and there's other
things like climate change that people
are all over the place on right so how
do you sort of bring everyone to the
middle and a kind of common core
understanding you know I asked me here
ago I what is that the answer was
clearly and articulately show the data
but we know from building businesses and
we know from what happened with Facebook
and Cambridge any other that's not the
case that's only half of it right half
of it is hidden understanding the other
half of it maybe even 75% of it is
marketing and getting the word out there
right because there's only 24 hours in
the day and no one no one is competing
kokis no longer competing with Pepsi
everybody is competing for our time
right and our attention right and so how
do you how do you there's no revenue
model talking about things being
sustainability how do you build
sustainability into getting the word out
there right about gun violence or
humanitarian crisis overseas right or
cyber governance with a artificial
intelligence right like how do you build
these sustainable models to get that
there I think for the most part you know
that's nonprofits are starting to say be
corpse we're starting to see better ways
of doing this but there is some huge
problems to be solved man like there's
so much you know I would love to see
over overpopulation is is not something
people like to talk about but that's
happening you know there's 7 billion
people on the planet and there's enough
food right and so how do we how do we
sustain that right and maybe the answer
lies in by us going to Mars we figure
out new farming methods that unlock the
potential to feed a population of that
size right but there needs to be more
people working in science in my opinion
and and getting the word out there and
solving these things in a responsible
ethical ethical way yeah and
then this is perfect segue into the next
question go go go for it and telling us
the pinker arguments true everyone's
coming up over time but what are we
really doing about the exacerbation of
all these technologies that are helping
the super-rich right now but that are
more slowly affecting the super poor and
how do we figure out what to do moving
forward
well I mean I don't I don't know that I
have the answer right but unfortunately
like it's weird how this is all it's
also connected right cuz like it's we're
still having the same conversation right
because you know teachers don't teach it
right you need to have matters but you
need to have access to those mentors
right and so if you grew up in a certain
situation where you didn't have an
environment that fostered those mentors
right but then you don't learn those
lessons and then you stay in the same
situation right and so whereas if you
grow up in an environment you know in
country clubs right where you're
surrounded by rich people and that's all
anyone's talking about is like
so you pick that up and then you figured
out how to do that yourself right and so
it's all about the environment and the
good news is that the Internet breaks
that a little bit right in a good way
where you can come up somewhere and
follow you know so the reason I am in
venture capital is because a guy from my
hometown of Buffalo Chris Sacca was a
venture capitalist and I started
following on Twitter and hearing about
what he was doing I was like oh this is
interesting and I if he tweeted a link
to an article I would read it right so
you could sort of start to use the
internet to to find ways and learned
things if you're awake enough to look
for other paths right to our point
earlier and so I think the Internet will
help to some extent but then the the
problem that immediately comes once that
happens is the bar goes up right because
the moment you have more people playing
the game competition gets higher and
it's harder to succeed within it right
you got more more stronger baseball
players then it's gonna be harder to
beat the Yankees right and so it's a
chicken and an egg problem but I do
think that the internet will help solve
it to an extent and I think as
blockchain blockchain is basically a
decentralized version of the Internet
right so we're basically again it takes
these like pockets of information and
then just breaks them up even more and
puts them around the world on separate
servers and it democratizes access to
them right you don't have to pay to
necessarily have a subscription to The
New York Times to get that information
you can you know give it through a mined
token or whatever right so I think the
internet will help solve it it will also
simultaneously raise the bar but you
know to your point earlier I think
people just we need we need people to
know that they need mentors to get
mentors right and we need people that
are good mentors to realize that
just how valuable taking a half-hour of
coffee to help someone else out is right
because this this is what happens as
well as if I'm really good at
throwing a baseball or starting a
company right maybe that comes naturally
to me right and so but I feel like I
still have so much to learn I'm not that
great right and you you don't people
don't always appreciate how naturally
good they aren't things and and and then
therefore just how much value they could
be giving someone else who is a little
bit further behind right and so having
that self-awareness to know that you can
give back to try to get back to set time
aside to give back what will help you
know I don't know how I'm not sure how
we do that on a global scale but maybe
there's a startup idea that there for
someone yeah you
I like how you looped it back to what we
were talking about earlier though
importance of mentorship importance of
uplifting people and underprivileged
unities and getting like you said a
mentor in that underprivileged community
it's gonna help so much access to
technology like uterus in the
underprivileged areas gonna help so much
with the accessor bation of wealth
inequality maybe they can even leapfrog
up and catch up faster so we can fill
that gap hotdogs done it all comes down
to information and and yes the what
information at an information access the
information highway we just knocked
m.l.king and Susan Clem sack at the
South End Tech Center in Boston and they
were totally all about that how close
are you to the information highway do
you have to drive 15 minutes or take a
bus 15 minutes to get to the information
superhighway or is it right in your
pocket already so there's that there's
so much more but how about I ask you a
question and then we'll we'll end with
you what do you think is the most
beautiful thing in the world
yeah all right this is tricky so I was
thinking about this as I was listening
to your episode of the dáil and it's
interesting cuz he broke it down by time
and you know the fridges most people
think today but you know time was the
most beautiful thing long term I have to
say I think it's honestly just like
right like I got a degree in cognitive
neuroscience I helped founder start
companies which is kind of people
choosing the other path and and honestly
almost an extension of my degree where
I'm trying to understand how people can
navigate the world and I'll tear your
ways right so it's its life man it's
it's you know something happens before
we're born but none of us can remember
it it's just an infinite blackness but
other people can remember it they
existed during that time so stuff must
have happened right and then and then
we're we were created and we have a
childhood and and then here we are as
adults where hopefully we're not just
meandering down some path that other
people told us to do or we're figuring
out our passions we're figuring out what
we care about right we're trying to
figure out how to manifest that into
reality right like that's beautiful
right like literally taking something
that's just an idea in your head and and
making it real and other people are
touching it and it's helping them write
like you prose in this podcast and
they're gonna listen and learn from that
right that's good - Mack - his
information actually the most beautiful
thing it's like it's it's one it's life
but then it's to making the most of that
right and and being able to hopefully
when we're older look back and say I
didn't waste any of it if I did waste
some of it I had a good time I spent it
with friends I spend it with friends and
you know family and but I don't think
that's time wasted either right so yeah
that's a super high level super generic
question but I think this this all this
just around us is his life and actually
want to touch on something to your point
I was reading on your website
hundred billion people have lived and
died before us and this was a actually
on your and your personal website and
you said you know we are just 7.5
percent of all the people that have ever
existed the other 92 billion
built the homes the school's the
hospitals the water mains the gas lines
the economies that we now have that give
us food water right so it's really just
this beautiful tapestry and what are we
gonna contribute to that tapestry yes
that's that's beautiful in my mind I
love that I love how you answer that I
love the analogy you made it's the
tapestry it's the social fabric that's
been made by this life life is the most
beautiful thing and what we make what we
made together to get to here and then
how are we going to contribute as we've
been born into it yeah yeah
loving it awesome well Ellen I wanna
thank you for for coming on the coming
on my show and having me on your show
and I'll do a quick shameless plug for
anyone listening and I'm simulation if
you want to check out ambition today we
are anywhere podcasts are found I've got
some great guests on some of the same
guests if anyone wants to give it up
terior story and likewise if you're
listening on ambition today be sure to
check out simulation Alan has bring the
other an amazing daily show here
and yeah thanks for doing this I'm
excited we'll have to do it again in the
near future yeah Kevin this was an
absolute blast thanks everyone for
tuning in definitely go check out
ambition today with Kevin Sisk our go
check out some of the work that the
founder Institute does and get inspired
and potentially get started with your
business find those mentors around you
that can help push you find those
alternative paths and walk down them and
inspire other people to do the same
think about what your values are what
your principles are build on that into
the future thanks for tuning in like
comment subscribe we'd love for you to
join the family join us on patreon check
out ambition today
much love everyone thank you Kevin for
tuning in from New York we appreciate
you so much thanks Ron Vargas our
producing partner peace everyone take
care of stay curious everyone they
curious
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]